justement l'un des grands pôles qui
accueille les malades de l'aco vide le
chru de tours s'attend à voir affluer de
plus en plus de patients dans ces
prochaines semaines
depuis le début de la deuxième vague mi
octobre l'établissement a reçu 74
patients en réanimation et le pic n'est
pas encore passé au printemps dernier
lors de la première vague
il en avait reçu 75 au total reportage à
l'hôpital bretonneau hélène chapelet
amélie et marie s'équipent pour rentrer
dans la chambre d'un patient atteint du
coup vide 19
l'homme de 64 ans est arrivé le week-end
dernier et depuis il a été placé sous
respirateur
ce patient plongé dans un coma
artificiel est en position ventrale
toutes les deux heures c'est soignante
doivent donc lui tourner la tête pour
éviter les points d'appui et vérifier en
même temps que la sonde du respirateur
n'a pas bougé
toutes les chambres du service sont
mises en dépression pour éviter que
l'air contaminé ne s'échappe de la pièce
toutes sont également équipés d'un sas
pour préparer le matériel avant d'entrer
et faire les transmissions
d'informations donc ici donc on commence
par se laver les mains puis après on
s'habille avec les blues
les blues les masques les lunettes et la
charlotte et et puis juste avant de
rentrer et on met un tablier pour se
protéger un peu plus et puis une fois
équipé on peut rentrer dans la chambre
pour procéder aux soins il ya un autre
travail habituel avant l'apparition du
coronavirus dans ce service de médecine
interne le quotidien c'était les avc les
arrêts cardiaques des crises d'asthme
sévère ou des tentatives de suicide
aujourd'hui sur les 35 lits du service
27 sont déjà occupés par des patients
qu'aux vide pour faire face à la
deuxième vague qui s'annonce massive
d'autres lits vont être libérés
notamment en réanimation chirurgicale et
neurochirurgicale on a eu pour l'instant
74 patients dans le service
on en a vu 75 pour la première vague or
la deuxième est loin d'être finie ont
clairement pour nous la vague est plus
importante car on est en phase de montée
en charge actuellement on a 27 placer
dans le service il y a trois quatre
patients en chirurgie cas l'on va dans
le week-end augmenter ses capacités avec
dix lits supplémentaires
et puis on va continuer à développer nos
capacités dans le courant de la semaine
prochaine
aujourd'hui au chru de tours les
patients traités dans ce service ont
entre 40 et 80 ans avec une moyenne
d'âge autour de 65 ans ils sont
majoritairement en surpoids et
présentent parfois des déficits
immunitaires